you know
steve used to do the poo condom or the
uh to smuggle weed
you know across state lines yeah what
are some of the clever ways that like
maybe you guys
used to transport drugs internationally
if you can talk about that uh
yeah um sorry to throw on the spot there
i'm just curious about like you know
put it up in your nutsack to get through
tsa or i mean what
yeah i wouldn't i'd never put it like in
or on my body
i say in um uh always um
two places come to mind real quick um
going through whether it's
in the air or on the ground on the
ground if you're on your tour bus
um they have very much like stevo's got
here
on on this truck in the in the back
you'd pop it up just by hand it was like
it's
almost like an emergency exit it is
doubles as a
an emergency exit and for ventilation
so we'd [__] be uh [__] we're getting
to the border
[__] roll over windows blow the smoke
out i'll [__] make sure everything's
cool
and grab whatever [__] drugs we have
and pop that thing open but you you
couldn't do it like going down the road
fast
[__] would fly off the bus so as soon as
we stop and pull into immigrations
or customs or whatever that [__] pop the
top
nice and slow take the [__]
everything
put it up on the roof of the bus and
close the [__]
that close the ventilation [__] dogs
immigrations dudes you know uh come
through the bus
all right all good see you guys later
and as soon as the [__] bus door is
shut boom
pop that up pull it in
that way that would have been great in
the movie yeah i know
and then you know then i think of the
airplane same
same deal uh like the headliner here you
know
you know they're like in an airplane
they've got you know that you've got
your headline or upholstery
your private plane yeah okay and [__]
yeah
yeah so we'd take take [__] cocaine
whatever it was do as much as we could
before we get there
um whatever was left we'd stick
like i felt above my seat for some
reason there was a little [__]
rip in the headliner so we'd [__]
get the [__] bag of blow and just
really crank it down
as little as we could and [__] just
like
to kind of you know get it up inside the
headline or kind of put it back
it was like a little little p little
like uh
like a little piece of double sided like
double stick tape and just
and you couldn't even tell it was just
like this and then it's in the headliner
same thing
dogs and i'm sitting there dude [__]
poo-poo in my pants just like oh my god
just geeked out
just freaked out that the dog's gonna
[__] come stop
and then jump on my lap and then [__]
right never
the dog i don't know it's too high or
or or i don't know but we pulled that
off several times and
never got busted can you imagine though
that that's what i was shooting my pants
could you imagine getting busted with a
[__]
ton of cocaine [__] singapore going
to dude
just certain places will [__] yeah
you just lock you up forever
you know there's no like oh you know
in a couple years yeah you got to sign
that thing before you get into singapore
saying that
the death penalty if i bring drugs into
this yeah yeah i think bali's like that
too there's some places where
they don't [__] play around yeah
dude